Rafi to recursive proofs and more
importantly what each of these things
are the material for this talk is based
on recent papers with several great
colleagues some of them are here Nick
there is also a Mary somewhere in
Tsongas here maybe a hiking song and dev
not here okay okay so these are
references there are there online if you
want to read about them so I will a what
I want to discuss today is a new
methodology for recursive snarks I will
explain what cursive snarks are I should
also clarify that the emphasis of this
talk is specifically on a let's call it
concrete efficiency so in a sense that
snarks a are being proofs of knowledge
and succinct we know that there occurs
and but we want to recurse them in
practice with actual implementations and
in these recent works who discovered a
very interesting connection between an
information theoretic concept something
called holographic proves there is
strongly connected to efficient
recursion of snarks through the notion
of people sitting snark okay so that's
kind of the way the structure goes and I
will have you know to Chile rather quick
parts for the talk all right so we only
have half an hour first I will explain
you why a recursion of snarks is
particularly efficient when you start
from a so called pre-processing snark
second of all I will explain why this
information theoretic notion of
holographic proofs directly leads to a
pre-processing snarks okay that's a plan
let's start with the first part actually
what why should one care this
methodology we have found it to be quite
general in a sense that it leads to
recursive snarks of very different types
to quite different examples is that you
can apply this methodology to obtain a
quite efficient pairing based recursive
snark so based on so called Universal
setup Universal structured reference
drink that's what era as the rest stands
for or alternatively
quite different would be post quantum
and transparent recursive snark sis now
you're only using kind of random
Oracle's and hash functions and here
transparent means that you're only using
again so no trapdoors
okay so part one why is the cursory
composition in pre-processing related so
first let me remind you what is the
recursive composition motivating example
is for instance to say that you want to
prove the iterated application of a
given function f okay a you know do it a
once that one application of F at a time
so you have some proving procedure
depends on F that produces a first proof
for this statement let's say that F
applied on some input 0 gives you the
output z1 right and in a second step you
would have the proving procedure
actually build on the prior proof and
produce a new proof for a statement that
F applied twice from 0 gives you z2 okay
but you don't wanna start from the
beginning you want to leverage the fact
that you already proved the first step
okay you want to prove incrementally
many times until you know some number of
times T this is say the teeth
application of f10 and you want it to be
so that at any moment in time including
at this point you can check quickly the
correctness of this say computation no I
was just simplifying in fact it is
useful and and interesting the fact that
you can provide different inputs at
different iterations here it was just a
particular example
now you can formalize this through
something called incrementally verify
the computation is what guys spoke about
yesterday and more generally something
called proof carrying data that
generalizes this notion not just online
graphs but I need the rate directory
cyclic graphs and there are applications
of these notions you can for example
construct relation a snarks for
MapReduce computer
you can actually build something called
verifiable delay functions is actually
the very actual construction you will
get a verifiable delay function if you
do this you can build 16 block chains
Issac is here and has co-founded a
company precisely in this direction and
also can prove BPD hardness as I
actually learned yesterday I hope I got
the references right now in all of these
settings the reason why doing these
proofs of proofs is even make sense is
because you have some form of fast
replication okay that the N P statement
that this procedure is called upon to
check is of course the invocation of F
on the primary input plus checking the
prior proof and you want this private
proof to be faster checking that proof
to be faster than a the statement it was
attesting to otherwise you're just
accumulating more and more gates to
prove and there's no point to do it
incrementally now let's try to kind of
look under the hood and see specifically
what costs arise when you try to kind of
recurse you prove things recursively
okay any particularly we need to clarify
what do we mean by faster if occation so
now I'm gonna make make that precise
okay so you could say well let's
consider machine computations
I'll just informally call this a
relation m set.all so let me point to
the fact that today i'm gonna be using
relations that are actually triples not
pairs why I want to specifically
separate kind of the description of a
computation M the machine from its input
that says I want to run em on X for so
many steps okay this is the weakness I'm
going to look at relations they're
actually triples a if for example I'm
focusing on machine computations faster
education will say that I am able to
produce a proof such that my
verification procedure is polynomially
related to the description of the
machine and you know the input so let's
let's make sure that this makes sense
if I read the machine obviously I will
read the maybe the finite automaton that
represents the Turing machine or can
think about as the program the input to
the program and the time bound in binary
so that cost me locti this is compared
to the complexity of the running the
computation it's M times T okay so this
could be much much larger than
representing and the statement itself
that I'm checking so snark for machine
computations we achieve sixteenth
verification if you're able to check
proofs let's say polynomially in this
expression when I say polynomially I'm
folding into it security parameter and
so on and so forth right this is what
faster education means lately we do know
that there is practical work that says
whenever you have a snark of knowledge
say of this sort then you can do a
recursive composition but today I'm
going to talk about P processing because
I want to motivate that so I'm also
gonna bring in as a comparison circuit
computations okay we're now the machine
is replaced by an explicitly written
circuit okay again it's a triple Yoba
circuit the input to the circuit a
partial input to the input to the
circuit and the rest okay and of course
the representation of the statement that
I'm checking which is CNX is roughly the
size of C right so in this case you
would think okay
I might be able to get a short proof but
certainly I will not be able to get
faster education because guess what have
to read the circuit okay
however threes are he setting of snarks
that it's called pre-processing snarks
that led to achieve fast certification
how a you have some offline procedure
that is done once and for all for a
particular circuit that generates a so
called verification key that is
specialized to the circuit at hand okay
think about it you know as a mental
picture you hash the circuit and you
keep its hash in your pocket okay and
then you can check and anybody can do
this okay there's no maybe trapdoors to
see to that and then every time you
check a proof relative to that you will
place a login see okay all I want you to
take away from this slide is that we
have two incomparable settings for
faster if occasion one is we're gonna
achieve faster vacation for some
computations without pre-processing
which some we're the ones with the
description of the computation is much
smaller than computation itself and the
other setting is that we can achieve
faster vacation for all computations say
arbitrary circuits but we're going to
have pre-processing okay these are
formal incomparable okay
now theoretical work in cursive snacks
tends to focus on sort of this sort of
clear a cleaner simpler sort of
formulation of fast replication I want
to now tell you about why this setting
here is particularly suitable for
recursion
what does not so you're saying who does
this or
so like I'm saying like in the machines
and you can have this scheme that's
adapted first we said first you choose a
CRS and then that bursary chooses so I'm
not gonna discuss security finishes but
I'm I am let's say that by default I'm
assuming you know full adaptivity and
all relevant parameters for they not
just not just that but if we use it for
recursion you need sufficient at
opportunity in your soundness and not
just soundness you need sufficiently
adaptive proof of knowledge because you
need to extract but for example just the
second owner for example it is okay for
the adversary to choose which say X to
prove things about as a function of the
variation key itself okay similarly here
it would be okay to choose even M X and
T as a function of whatever parameter is
the the snarky snark will have some
setup and it's okay to pick them
adaptively and this is important for
recursion we had a question it better be
deterministic or at least you can it
could be probably stating we have to
publish the randomness for others to
reproduce I mean there are other
separate issues that I don't want to
discuss right now that are not about
that
clearly if it is has probably coin you
have certain things that might go wrong
but even if it's public though I am
assuming apptivity throughout the talk
and I'm not going to talk about it
further unless
okay so now I want to explain is
probably the only difficult slide in the
tire talk okay like really I would
explain why the pre-processing helps in
recursion for that I have to show you
how you actually go about and do things
recursively so so here's the machine I'm
describing a machine our four recursion
that will implement this incremental
application of F that I had as an
example of beginning of the slide I
became the talk so it takes two inputs
the input X and the witness W the input
X it will parse it as a description of
some arbitrary machine for now it's not
the same one just some arbitrary machine
the counter where we are and the current
acclaimed output the witness will
contain a previously claimed out output
and a prior proof it will check the
transition is applied correctly and if
you're not in the base case it will
check the power proof now check the
power proof you have to specify which NP
statement you're going to be checking
against so it specifies this prior
instance with the counter one less with
the prior output and it specifies that's
going to be relative to the Machine M
which is an input to the computation
right so later what you do is you set m
to be the machine
R okay so it will actually R will be
called upon checking computation and
involves itself on an input okay I could
have also invoked the recursion theorem
but probably nobody has it loaded in
their head and I just kind of did like a
poor man's version of recursion theorem
using the environment here okay so right
but the point is that now you prove that
the machine are accepts on input X i
where I've replaced the description of
my description of our specifically are
okay so there's not there's nothing that
is circularly find you know I really can
roll it okay and you would run verify on
this okay
okay that's easy I could do literally
the same thing or almost the same thing
in a circuit world except that now I
don't put the description of a circuit
here because doesn't make sense the
circuit I mean I don't want the the
circuit to read descriptions of circuits
really what it should receive is
verification keys okay so you see have
replaced this by very high friction keys
okay and similarly when I'm proving I
will pass in as an input to the circuit
are its own verification key okay
generated based on our so what this is
just a syntactic change but here's the
punchline let's look at what is the cost
of the recursion let's say as a function
of F what I would like is that the cost
of proving things about F is as close to
F as possible I don't want like my cost
enough to blow up so here if you notice
I am going to pay for a cost in F that
is pretty steep why
where does f live F is hard-coded in
description of R and R is passed as an
input to R itself so it means that the
machine R is called upon to interpret
the description of F and check it this
will cost you some number of logical
steps just to figure out where is our
you know where is F what does it look
like let me kind of execute it and see
if it's running okay so will pay that at
least some most people will cost and
it's gonna be like a non trick like
highly non-trivial constant here plus
other stuff including the verifier and
everything but at least you have a cost
here in reprocessing it's not gonna
happen
you are just considering a circuit and
I'm gonna take F and I place it in a
particular place in the circuit there is
no parsing no interpretation you can
think about this as the difference
between some hardware recursion and some
software records
oh I'm sorry this F should be this F I
know they're completely different
symbols but this F here in the what I'm
trying to measure is I have a predicate
or a function I want to recursively
apply at each step and I want to measure
the cost of my record recursion as a
function of that predicate
let's take us of f as a circuit in both
cases and if it's a machine then I will
have to write here time F yes everything
I was iterating you can think of f is
let's say it's a circuit in the number
of gates the point being is that in
harder recursion I pay one okay that's
it and what has happened is that
pre-processing has replaced the
description of our with a 16
cryptographic commitment to it okay this
is something is will always happen with
the pre-processing snark okay let's
think about it the circuit it is
hard-coded it in the machine R and the
Machine R is called to run on an input
that involves R as its description of
our and it has to check F so it has to
kind of decode or parse F somewhere its
input and run it so it receives us the
description of a circuit has to check
for concrete I mean maybe I'm just
saying that for a pre-processing start
this is I can do it I can actually prove
it or every pre-processing snark this is
the case like this is for natural
constructions of actually I really don't
in this constant like I said I've
thought my colleagues quite a while
about this constant they're just really
not nice okay it's a nice open problem
to see whether there exists something on
the left or you could have something
like C equals one but on the right you
definitely have it s equals one because
you're doing harder recursion
but is the illegal side of the talk a so
and you can prove things that you know
any proposing snarky curses and you
always have under some very mild
conditions you always have this kind of
a non multiplicative cost in recursion
so this is something that we analyzed in
a recent worker she also point out that
a recursion preserves your knowledge it
also preserves important properties such
as post quantum security we didn't know
that before now we know that if you
start with a post quantum snark you can
recurse you'll get a post quantum say
incrementally verify the computation and
prove current data and maybe are not as
small remark is the recursion preserves
the type of spare to set up so if you
have a pre-processing snarky that
actually does have a private coin set up
that depends on the circuit you will get
a circuit specific recursion and this is
actually what is deployed today we know
it's constructed from Lehrer interactive
proofs and pairings and in hindsight the
reason why we were able to have
efficient realizations of recursion is
because we paste it in pre-processing
snarks now we see today why it was like
much more practical than alternatives
okay there's like a common explanation
for all pre-processing snarks the role
of so-called paring friendly pick cycles
elliptic curves to make this practically
just to make this smaller but it doesn't
like the statement to the pre-processing
helps is just true regardless okay so
what is holography come in has to do
with this other very interesting setting
like this today we we are very
interested in setups that are universal
you start it up say for all circuits up
to a certain size or or or you just have
public own set up and we don't really
have a very good explanation of where
pre-processing snarks in these other
settings come from and what I'm gonna
explain in a think five minutes suffice
yeah is that it comes from whole graphic
proofs okay so the last one so far is
that if you're interested in a cursive
composition
especially if efficient one you should
care about requesting snarks if you care
about pre-processing snarks then there
are different types of roasting snarks
as a function of which setup you are
considering and the practically
interesting setups typically are the
ones that are universal or or or
transparent then you would like to have
a methodology to construct
pre-processing snarks in those settings
ok and there is a very direct connection
with from holography to this setting yes
just I put in parentheses here uniform
reference drink
that's just a reference string that is
fully random question alright and that
will it basically handles these cases so
all I really want is to explain what is
holography and and it was like extremely
simple compiler it tells you how to how
to go from holography to pre-processing
so let me take as a running example
again CSAT and i'm going to talk about
pcps but the concepts are I discuss
really applied interactive proofs
interactive ECP's interactive ergo
proofs they're kind of orthogonal like
to the specific type of proof that you
have you can also apply them to NP
so standard proofs you have the
traditional notion of completeness and
soundness it says that if you're in the
in the relation then the honest prove it
will give you a proof that makes it very
far accept and if you're not ok if
there's no weakness that makes see
accept input X then you reject with some
you accept that most with some
probability regardless of the proof
now in the setting of arbitrary
computations we don't touch si si is too
big okay we have to take it out of the
verifier and put it somewhere okay now
there are two classical answers to doing
this one is proximity proofs okay you
just say yeah you have Oracle access to
see okay now to actually make it
possible for the verifier to touch see
at a small number of locations you
actually have to relax your decision
question you're really going to consider
this kind of proximity version of
soundness that you're not gonna check
this condition instead you're gonna
check let's say that C if C is that the
far from all C star that make X be
satisfied with that make ax a good input
then you're gonna reject okay I don't
really know how to weaponize this for
our snarks it's a fine notion and we use
it as a tool to construct many useful
things but there's no trouble equation
you can do which is holographic proofs
you're gonna say okay we take out see
from the very fire but now it's gonna be
kind of encoded in some form there is
some algorithm we call it the indexer
because I'm thinking of CS kind of the
index of a relation R sub C that takes C
and spits out some some string based on
C okay and now you get to keep your
original promise except that now the
verifier has access to this process yeah
like it's a yes it's here like that
that's that's what it is and that's what
you have access to
so that's a sort of general notion of
holographic proofs any questions about
this one
simple right so it's a simple clean
notion it's terminal to proximity proofs
and
it ends on how good is your proof system
similarly just how big is pi as a
function of C you know all these are
parameters of the proof system if you
build whole graphic proofs
you better care about the size of IFC
that would be one additional measure of
complexity that you want to keep under
control because if you don't then you
you pay for it
so in these two papers we actually
explore this connection from holography
to pre-processing in two different
settings one is this information theory
compiler that we proved that any
holographic PCP or more generally
interactive Oracle proof leads to a
pre-processing snark in the quantum
random Oracle model okay so this is a
real an information theoretic statement
there is nothing but random Oracle's and
actually a very simple compiler to
explain a another is a cryptographic
compiler it says let's consider
something called an algebraic
holographic proof essentially it's the
same thing but you talk about
polynomials instead of strings and you
can compile it into a pre-processing
snark in the square RS model what is
Square well it's either SRS or urs
depending upon how good is your
extractable internal commitment scheme
okay so you have some polymer commitment
scheme in some model you inherit it here
maybe these are two very different
settings information threading
cryptographic we're kind of the kind of
this stealing the notion of holography
and just just me being honest to
yourself that actually we were talking
about all along makes it very easy to
see where pre-processing comes from by
the way when you take the random Oracle
you instantiate it URI stickily you will
get something in the URS model
it was just no this is just saying that
this is like a classical construction in
the random Oracle model that in addition
to being information theoretic say click
here against classical adversary's with
bounded access to the Oracle it is
moreover secure against quantum
adversaries that make bound the number
of queries to the Oracle so this is a
statement about post quantum security in
the yes up here this is about
information theory compiler in the
random Oracle model there is nothing but
random Oracle's so the the statement is
something like this you have a unbounded
quantum algorithm there has a
superposition access to the random
Oracle this is the standard setting of
the quantum random Oracle model I didn't
make it up it's a paper yeah and but you
have but the limit of the the quantum
algorithm is the number of queries to
the Oracle but they can mean
superposition
never superposition queries right and
you want to relate the soundness error
of the compiled protocol to this bound
ok and the kinds of statements you
probably want to prove is something like
this if your PCP has say a soundness
error epsilon which is you know it's not
about quantum it's about the PCP out
here you will get say a soundness error
that is maybe T times epsilon plus
something small against T bound the
quantum adversary's
I not aware of connections it is
everywhere so this this uses is
compressed article formalism so this is
a the in differentiability the like
sponge constructions in differentiable
fin the random or we can explain the
offline I mean there is many things yeah
for now let me just say that they
statement the queue here just saying
these construction is post quantum
secured information theoretically
against is there some connection between
the second one here and the sparking
work it feels like is you could imagine
generalizing it to a compiler from mokey
Boober interacted first with sort of
index or C which is I believe that if
you work hard enough it would be a
special case by hard enough I mean that
it actually matters which properties of
the put on government scheme kind of
make this transition go through so I
want to conclude with my last slide
which is actually want to tell you
information through a compiler is very
simple it's so it's kind of so simple
that it's and we think about it only now
so step a we just apply the makai
transformation and we leave the indexer
zzzz
so you have your PCP you apply the
Macaulay transformation and you will get
some sort of holographic snark right
that somehow because the Makai
transformation never really touched the
PCP verifier if before the PCP refire
was happy talking to an encoded circuit
then he continues to be happy talking
when career sector because there's a was
a tiny PCP very fire here talking with
the outside world so this really as a
block I am applying the Makai
transformations or block books and it's
kind of cleaner what you should do it
says look do you want you wanna answer
queries about the this string I of see
just in an offline stage just take your
circuit and code it store your routine
are in a verification key put the rest
for the prover and during the actual
proving figure out which query is the
verify wants to make package them up in
a proof send it along and random
Calavera fire answering
you know like this and that's it okay so
in the information theory compiler is
just basically the observation that if
you have an extra kind of offline kind
of PCP that is just about the circuit
it's not about computation then you can
just push it into a miracle tree once
and for all
okay yes it's a good question and you
know this is one of the things one can
prove yeah and in fact here you don't
even need to use the analysis of
Macaulay in the random Oracle model you
can just use actually the way we prove
this is by just using the collision
bound
there are separations but I know if
there are natural ones okay okay let me
just conclude and say that we have whole
graphic proofs in fact we have classical
or graphic proofs before last is one of
them that already gives you a very
interesting results in pre-processing we
did not know if pre-processing snarks
that are post quantum now we do just
even by applying v4 as the bare bones
GTR protocol is also a graphic proof and
what nick talked about earlier today
basically gives rise to eventually
holographic proofs with reasonable
parameters including the indexer so this
goes back to your question that the
encoding size will be linear in a
circuit and you can you can obtain it in
with my 50
okay I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
conclude here I think you can ask me
offline so what I told you today is new
methodology for recursive snarks I
explained why if you care about the
recursion deficiency recursion you
should care about pre-processing snarks
and then if that's all your new target
then a good way to reach it is by
designing with holographic proofs
[Applause]
yeah of course yeah sure let me let me
go through these so I so I put here two
pre-processing snarks that are generated
using holographic proofs these are two
recent papers and I am plotting for each
of these two things
the closest representative benchmark so
for example this one is a pre-processing
snark in the universal SRS model and I'm
comparing it against the best circuit
specific pre-processing snark service
resuming the pre-processing is a is
based on the circuit the other benchmark
here is I'm comparing a pre-processing
snark in the quantum an Oracle model and
instantiate the heuristic using hash
functions and I'm comparing against the
best non pre-processing a what's quantum
snark and I think this is actually very
interesting graphs in there's some I
think high-level takeaways for everybody
one is that prover time basically
doesn't matter like all of these systems
are within a factor of ten or one
another you might think or factor of ten
is a lot but in the grand scheme of
things these are using very different
tools different sensations and the fact
that all provers are within a factor of
ten and all of this is again for rank
one constraint systems okay is to me
interesting like it's saying like all
the provers are to a first approximation
kind of doing the same thing
encoding f of T is and doing some
interesting stuff underneath another
interesting takeaway is also the very
fires that for all pre-processing snarks
all very fires are pretty fast we're
talking about from two to ten
milliseconds again they're all pretty
good what's this line well it's the only
non pre-processing snark here where the
verification time grows linearly well of
course it goes up but this is basically
saying it to me
verification time is not really like a
separation between these approaches
performance wise what distinguishes a
lot between these is the proof size
circuit specific pre-processing snarks
give you ridiculously small proofs less
than hundred bytes if you go universal
you'll get you know less than one and a
half kilobyte okay why are they writing
here instead of in the graph because
this
to the fourth right so they would be
like down here and you wouldn't be able
to see the difference between these here
it's basically saying that the cost of
pre-processing relative to non
pre-processing is you know within a
factor of two okay so the difference
between all these schemes really like
boils down to proof sizes and then of
course the different setups and whether
they post quantum or not so then some
empathy for us to the audience so I
think we should take a break
[Applause]